this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
you
April the 19th 2011 session in our
series on entrepreneurship in Asian
high-tech industries we have another
panel session today about Asian
entrepreneurs who have been successful
or are being successful in the United
States and I'm looking forward to our
discussion Oh for students who are
registered for credit remember that your
comments are due by email to me with a
cc to Tiffany our courses under of
course assistant within two weeks of the
date of the session so the comments for
april fifth are due today now i actually
had to contact the TV network to find
out how to get to the slides on the
stanford website so i have found that
out and i'll send that out to the class
if you are not able to see the slides
and i'll also send out a note to
everybody who is in our big list about
how to see these as free seminars all of
the sessions will be available online in
streaming video until the end of the
quarter roughly mid mid june so i'm
really happy today that i have two
entrepreneurs on both from china who are
active in the united states furthest
away from me is you kai chou who is a
serial entrepreneur even at this point i
think and has just started a company
called reward me which is a mobile
loyalty management solution that's a
wonderful description and next to me is
dr. shirley Chen who is the founder and
CEO of a company called win vivo and
when vivo is making botanical based
natural therapeutics so I'm going to
refer you to our website for further
information about both of our presenters
today and
them if we can go on and get into our
presentations so first I'm going to ask
surely if you will take the floor and
let me give you the remote control for
the the slides and we should be ready to
go thank you Richard for inviting me
again to your cause it was one half
years ago I was invited by dr. Richard
Dasher to come and get you ever talk
about our new brand new company well one
half years later what has happened to
our company oh well obviously we'll
still survive sorry and thriving okay as
you can see from the change-up logo what
you just saw is what we are now back and
with just started you got this
amateurish looking logo okay but we were
very enthusiastic because we thought
we're catching a very green tidal wave
at that point I started green revolution
in Silicon Valley without botanical
based products now we started with the
lower so called the blockbuster a
natural product called the healing balm
well look at this tire of it we just
want a ward for a package design okay so
that's pretty good for a little startup
company in Silicon Valley right but what
contained in this pretty little box is a
very powerful natural product that can
you the most difficult to heal wounds I
would say it's probably best in the
world later I'll show you the examples
but look at the big picture here what
our companies focusing on are not I mean
chronic health conditions a lot of you
hear or know that how serious are health
care problems in these countries is and
how difficult a sleek it is
to really treat and all prevent all
those are chronic conditions chronic
health problems specifically obesity
diabetes cardiovascular issues and in
fact a lot of us perhaps fifty percent
of our audience here and at the end
stage of diabetes you know that people
would suffer from massive tissue
necrosis and it's very hard to heal the
wounds and the may face amputation so
before I show you those clinically
graphic pictures I have to warn you okay
some of them are really very gross but
you enjoying the outcome though so here
in Silicon Valley I want to assure you
just a little thought about our
mentality here I think Silicon Valley is
a great place to start this kind of
business combine the high-tech fast pace
of innovation mode with the slow
nature-loving sustainability
tree-hugging kind of mentality I'm and
here people are very pragmatic they care
about solutions to problem if you got a
problem let's find a solution I don't
care about how much experimentation is
going to take whether it happens in your
garage or happens in your kitchen people
were just will jump at the opportunity
and try to find a solution that's how
we're doing here and you probably heard
the great reformer of China then shall
pain who used to say I have to say in
chinese first boob I'm Oh him Oh jal ja
ja house as usual homo anybody here
understand that okay he said I don't
care it's a black cat a white cat as
long as that cat catches the rat I call
him a good cat okay so that's why we're
the data to retake here is facing a
massive HEPA demek our chronic health
problems what you're going to do a lot
of people here in city
that if you ask them is it they're not
that they're not going to depend that
don't want to depend on prescription
drugs for the rest of their life to
solve the chronic health problems so
what can we do here as innovator in
Silicon Valley so I trained as a
biomedical scientist and Nobel Prize
winners lab and later became IP lawyer
Wilson Sonsini and well we have helped a
lot of startups in Silicon Valley
including biotech/pharmaceuticals ice
cosmeceutical you name it our clients
try to come up with the solutions to the
problem from every different angle but
what I can come up is something i would
say i wanted to go back to 3,000 years
of history a few menus of natural
products in treating and preventing
diseases because not because it's
because like where I came from China but
also I see the limitations of modern
medicine prescription drugs in treating
chronic conditions pacifically so we
beautiful international team combined
business people and natural product
experts and manufacturing facilities
across the Pacific from China to the to
the Silicon Valley and produce a launch
six products six products we need a year
for healthcare company in Silicon Valley
that's pretty fast okay so the first
product as I mentioned is a extremely
effective wound cleaning product I will
you know try to be time conscious so
here you can see in America own care
costs a lot of money and you see that
chronic wound wants especially
challenging or in terms of care and how
you can bring out a satisfactory outlook
outcome and you can see if it's not
treated well you may lose your leg or
your food okay so what do we have here
the healing balm is that it's a simple
topical
Ormond but it combines all the
components necessary for the whole long
healing process debridement and
infection Andrew Genesis and a promotion
of blood circulation and finally tissue
regeneration you can see that for this
massive necrosis on tissue necrosis
within three months the food can be hill
otherwise it could face amputation
period no problem and then this one is
also old man but him when he was young
he suffered a major wound and healed his
leg with a massive odd scar tissues but
later when he was hurt again 40 years
later because of the age is age the scar
tissue prevents it from healing properly
and just could not stop the UH necrosis
with the healing balm oh you can see
that you know if you save his leg and
then another this is a very tragic
incident but the outcome is extremely
exciting this is eight-year-old girl
accidentally grabbed an electric
electricals way guess what happened she
got electrified on a finger okay wound
you this is pretty gross so yeah did the
dr d braid her fingers and got rid of
the no char the tissue you see how fast
the tissue grows right in front of your
eyes you observe human tissue
regeneration within 21 days this young
girl got her finger back and completed a
restore of structure there's no of
course no imputation no contracture and
she totally normal well this is happy
this happened in China okay and now we
are repeating the same same clinic or
animal experiment
in the US and got extremely i would say
exciting results consistent with what's
happening in China and we obtained
exclusive license to this natural
product well you can if you compare the
story of products people here use all
the gadgets all that all the bottles are
all this stuff and nurses the telling us
that this is all they use they have to
have to use multiple component multiple
product to deal with one or the top
difficult to heal wounds sometimes the
wound just would not move at all but
with the healing balm it start to move
really quickly so it's very encouraging
and that's what you even more exciting
is the skin cancer area we found that
the healing balm not only filled it you
can see that I don't have time to go
through the detail clinical detail but
you can see after the birth brief
debridement you can see their healing of
the wounds okay and happening graduating
this old lady happening less than two
months the beauty of this is the massive
cancer tissue will now grow back that's
really significant she would not have to
go back to the clinic to go through this
oh so called the most surgery anymore
okay so fast forwarding now that company
is not just treating the topical skin
problems scratching on the surface
because you know that a lot of problems
like diabetes diabeetus ulcer the
problem stands from within and you can
see that because of your lack of a you
know strong immune defense you could be
subjected to all kinds of a problem
sometimes sometimes the problem
manifesting themselves in this scheme so
we develop this or can I can I interrupt
you for a second Oh questions i really
want to ask about the first product okay
okay is that based on traditional
chinese medicine indeed yes that's first
question second question is for a drug
company in the united states to develop
something that would be a prescription
drug you know part of this for whatever
purpose
you're talking hundreds of millions of
dollars and lots of clinical trials and
probably eight to twelve years so
exactly Richard so that's why we're
saying that Oh model it's quite
different from the traditional
pharmaceutical model you can call this
from a suit achill but I would not go
that far because I think this is can be
used for your home care even for
ordinary skin care in for people's a
little acne or rosacea so that first
product is over the counter are you so
over the counter okay not requiring a
prescription no and so you're doing
experiments to demonstrate the validity
but do you have to go through the FDA
clinical trial process or what you have
to do it that's a complicated regulatory
a question but I can answer that simply
that right now it's marketed as a skin
treatment or it meant to similar to the
way you can find on the shelf of whole
foods for skin problems okay the beauty
of this is that it get it has a while
your application ranges and you can use
it to treat a little burns and cuts and
garden and wounds and stuff and also
nurses home care professionals they can
use to treat the difficult to treat
wounds depending on how your aunt is
very easy to use it does not require any
special training so because of the way
you're describing it you're able to
basically avoid that whole process and
bring it to the market okay I without
the FDA process in this case i would say
that because it's formulated using
natural ingredients and botanicals just
like you know you see green tea in the
costly high-end the high-end are now not
even high-end anymore all there's a
natural herbal based skin care products
while they're available over the counter
in cosmetic shop Whole Foods a house
will store but I think here is more
about education and how people can be
convinced by the efficacy of your
product okay yeah keep going and and I
think about how much money it
save the consumers because as I IP
attorney I know that you know in order
to you know secure a position for your
product you have spent a lot of money on
the security patent filing and
everything later you want to go through
with all the custody clinical trials how
is how you're going to recover the cost
hundreds of millions of course you're
going to charge a very high price for
your product here what we have the jar
of others healing amazingly effective
healing only cost sixty dollars and a
jar of that can be used to heal a very
difficult to heal a diabetic ulcer that
could have cost you ten thousand dollars
if you ever got to heal at all sometimes
you have to be amputated anyway so
moving forward so we developed this oral
or natural products based on vegetables
okay so please we based we wanted to
develop modern type of natural
therapeutics based on the principle of
using food as medicine we don't have to
go and fund the strange I so tarek herbs
we just go and investigate what the
stuff for thousands of years people in
Asia and China Japan Korea how they use
ordinary you know herbs like you know
reishi mushrooms and shitake mushroom
your seed and alarming Chinese
restaurants and how to use to boost the
immune system at same time we combine
with those vegetables people eat a lot
in Vietnam Thailand like camellia
camellia plan and in a Japanese
honeysuckle that's a that's a very
popular antiviral antibacterial
botanicals we put them together and we
found out that this ordinary combination
can doubt you have a very good
protective broad-spectrum protective
effect so when you travel when you go to
conferences and you pair people coughing
and you're worried what was drained or
what superbug they carry at this point I
think you know before you even know what
what strain of super bug is is there you
can actually help your body to
act itself but give it a little gentle
boost all right you don't have to even
worry about specifically targeting that
particular strain so um you can you can
get to know about this salad by visiting
our website later on and then later we
can also find that this product can
actually do wonder alright I'm very
proudly to announce that it not only can
help people with the chronic sinusitis
you know overcome the nasal congestion
issue it actually brought back people's
sense of smell after they suffer a not
smear for a long time it's just it just
shocked the hell make it as a scientist
as well this shows it how powerful will
you combine the right kind of natural
ingredients they can actually help your
body reboot itself and then we take the
holistic approach of treating topical
problems with the systemic oral products
such as you know cold sore because of
the shingle herpes and also acne because
of a bacterial problem and eczema eczema
because of imbalance immune system and
we got very encouraging results and the
way you don't know how many people
actually suffer from others topical I
mean all these skin problems it's a
shockingly high percentage in this
country what I want to show you look
this carefully what what even more
shocking is that this natural products
we find that it can be also used to to
treat psoriasis and this is a guy who
suffer psoriasis I'm sorry psoriasis for
10 years and tried everything under the
Sun natural or prescription drug a
biologic you name it antibody antibodies
but then with with the potato guarded
natural capsules within three months his
skiing is clear and it's only way to
complete a recovery
and and no more itching okay hurry up so
um and data where would you rather put a
very effective lozenges for people with
a chronic cough problem and then we also
address the issue of broad-spectrum
allergy we now you know that a lot of
people complained about gluten
sensitivity and nothing you can do about
it there's no drug for it and all
doctors tell them there's this you know
just just avoid the thing and you know
you will be okay or your life quality of
life really is compromised and later we
found that it also works well for of
course Oh protein-based you know
allergens so you can see the approach
here is quite different from the magic
bullet pharmaceutical approach we're not
trying to the nail they are exactly what
a lodging is but you you you have to
build your body to be to cope with
broad-spectrum over-friendly this
supposed to be friendly on substances
why is reacting to yourself it's
sometimes your immune system is out of
balance so we take the eastern holistic
approach and develop product to address
this broadly okay here we go now you can
see that we wanted to present a very i
would say natural comforting and i would
say green image to the public and we
also wanted to design our product to
meet a busy lifestyle of modern people
especially people traveling so we come
up with a new packaging design while
later I can show you that how it can
meet people special needs so I
appreciate your time and ask me
challenging questions later thank you
very much
so shortly file i'm changing slides we
had we asked you to speak here of what a
year ago now and at that point i think
your first product was just beginning to
hit the market right so what an
incredible track record in one year yeah
we haven't told you about our third
class start class of products and I
think everybody here would want it
because you don't have a wound you don't
have psoriasis but you want to eat right
so we developed this a very effective
low calorie high fiber and a very okay
so who's wise who is we when vivo yeah
but this sounds like something you would
need 300 of you know pharmaceutical
engineers I don't thank you we have a
very you know i would say unique model
because for massive production that
capsules and ornament we have it in a
way are all source to companies in
california right here okay and the bars
we'd love to do it ourselves because we
are already we work with that experience
a vegan Baker the one hundred percent
plant-based vegan Baker came up with the
flavor and we'd love to engineer it and
make it won't tastier and we are the
first guinea pigs so yeah okay shn so
you know this is fascinating but i have
to say it remains a mystery to me but
cause as a startup company you know this
sounds like a level of activity that
just would take 10 times as many people
and really hundreds of millions of
dollars thank you we're ready starter
january revenue so that's pretty good
for health care also pretty good within
the first year of doing anything I mean
really but calls until your product
launched you had like six months I mean
I really don't think the company was
formed until like six months before
profit which was it we want to follow
the high-tech model richer ok now the
classic drug motto so we'll come back to
this whole issue of why
when VEVO is being successful that's
really kind of one of our main themes
for today in the meantime we'll move to
the high-tech model asked you guys to
talk about reward me and yeah go ahead
you got cool so LeBron very honored to
be here my talk well the first half of
my quick my talk would be just going
through a little bit about reward me how
it works what it does little about the
team and background but also since this
uh this panel is about being Asian and
starting a company in the US I'll also
share some of my experiences on the in
terms of what I see as some of
advantages as well as some obstacles
that a face me and being that so reward
me is a mobile loyalty management
solution and pretty much what it is is
it's a mobile application that allows
users to go to their favorite stores and
restaurants get points and redeem them
for free food or drinks or merchandise
so it's like a loyalty program on your
phone and we started this because we
notice that there's a lot of stores that
give you different types of loyalty
program your punch cards your little
swiping cards and then you realize you
have like 20 or 30 of them in your
wallet you take them out you always
forget them at home and then you have
like 10 punch cards the same company
same store that has one punch on it so
we want to consolidate all of this into
one solution and which which became
rewarding so first thing is to turn to
the next is it working it could because
this is PDF I'll pick your own there we
go ok ojala just tell me who the move
okay so a little background about our
team so we start the three core founders
of our company met at school at UCLA
little while ago and we've been working
on startups for over three years
together we worked on different
companies these are some of the projects
we've worked on some of them were where
you know there's ups and downs and some
of them were pretty promising 11 product
ft career was read on Mashable as one
who topped in social networks for Jen
wise unfortunately I was hit by the
economic crisis and we had to make a
switch in direction
and our core strength lies in social
media and gamification we have led
campaigns for some big brands like
Levi's activision lakers and warner
brothers and just basically help them go
into the social media world or they make
their processes more fun and interesting
for reward me where we were then joined
by another entrepreneur who was very
successful he's had for success in the
past one of them was sold for 850
million dollars and 120 27 and then
seven networks is profitable and number
two and in the research in motion space
so that's our core team that we formed
so what is reward me I kind of briefly
went over it but reward me is a loyalty
managed solution for the restroom
hospital and retail industries and so
far right now what we do is we give it's
a cure code based solution where you'd
bring your iphone and android to the
restaurant to the store and when you buy
something you scan the QR code with your
phone and it will say the ring you have
250 points you can then look in your
phone and see oh you know for 500 points
you can get a free burrito you know if a
thousand points you get something else
he also get rewarded by referring
friends so if you refer your friend your
friend goes and buy something then you
get double the points or there's
sometimes you can go in slow hours now
325 for four restaurants and you get
more points so it's basically making the
retail experience more fun and
interesting get more points you need to
share in the social web and it allows
stores to get more return on their in
their investment so again go in you get
points the the reversion right now is
still completely mobile base but we are
moving on to a generation two of our
product which is a tablet solution
actually which is we're providing
restaurants and stores a tablet kind of
like an iPad but probably a lot cheaper
than I've had and so that allow them to
to serve as any peep any customer
without them having a iphone or android
and so yeah so you just bring in your
stuff and you get your free stuff so
we've launched we're relatively new we
start working on this in September of
last year and we launched officially in
January at 18th so it's about three
months ago so in these three months we
have a lot of success in luck
we were managed to we managed to get
some pretty well known clients like
Denny's you know we have starbucks in
Vancouver what sell pretzels posh bagel
in Mountain View ever quickly and
usually a lot of the audience don't know
what quickly is but if it's if it's a
big asian crown everyone knows the
bo-best or yeah so so we're having some
good success for if we're almost for
only three months in and we have some
pretty good leads and getting more
customers what we're thankful for is
today as of today we're starting to get
inbound leads on our website almost on a
daily or every two days basis and you
know it's very rare for a company for
serve to create their stuff and then
three months later people just call and
say hey we want your solution so that's
something that was very useful for us so
that's my company and obviously you can
ask a lot more questions about my
company I then want to go into more of
the personal story of me and how I
started or the things I face so I moved
here from Taiwan in two thousand so
about 11 years ago I came here to study
and mostly it's because my father was a
diplomat and so so I grew up here I
studied you international economics in
UCLA so not very much of a technical
background my parents and my family murs
they all wanted me to study engineering
some science background and I think
that's a very popular mainstream way for
for Asian Americans to go and so but I i
decided that i really like business I
like interacting with people i like how
businesses operates together as a
machine itself so so then I just kind of
was rebellious and so I study economics
instead I created my first business
first year in college and the one that I
started first year was a very simple one
it was actually I think sr2 at the same
time one was more of aged online
retailing business selling electronic
products like digital camera on GPS what
I kind of did to start off was i would
go on ebay and I'd x TI 83 calculators
at two a.m. in the morning when no one
would bid against me and i'd buy them
for forty dollars and then 2 p.m. in the
day I would sell them and everyone's
bidding against each other sets other
for sixty dollars so i thought i was
kind of cool and fun i was a college
student and nothing
else better to do so so I just did that
for a while and then eventually I was
like hey you know why don't I buy like
other stuff products to or why don't I
sell new products so when in weren't the
digital camera space I sold some iPods
is the first few years of the original
white and fat iPod even though back then
it was thin and slick and I also started
another come more like a nonprofit
service we're just helping people
connect with other professionals more
like a like a linkedin and this time but
not as high tech and as a I guess purse
as a person was not born in the US I
have throughout the years I have faced a
lot of issues with having legal status
as entrepreneur in the States because
there's a very clearly defined visas for
you know technical workers who work here
their visas for the students their visa
for the executives but there are no
visas for the entrepreneurs so as an
entrepreneur it was very very
challenging to find out to figure how I
can stay here and continue to grow the
business you know become something that
creates value and hopefully hire more
people in the States and it's always
been struggle I can't talk too much
about it because some of it might get
into some questions its socialist on air
so when people asked about you know
coming from Asia is that helpful or not
or is there more problems I definitely
will say that there's a lot of obstacles
but at the same time there are some
advantages the advantage is very very
clear when your business is directly
related to research in Asia or getting
managed fact manufacturing hardware so
right now like I said we're going into
the more of a tablet space and we're
looking to build customized tablets that
because I'm from Asia I have a lot of
friends there have connections there I i
immediately got in touch with the people
who could create very very
cost-effective 'let's that can offer to
our customers so that's one big of
roundish but for a lot of entrepreneurs
out there you're mostly focused on
software products you know and you're
selling to businesses here you're not
dealing hardware and i would say coming
from Asia are just from from another
country has some huge advantages and one
is definitely just have a broader
expected perspective I think you you are
better geared to become an entrepreneur
is when you are born and raised and grew
up in the exact same area a lot of
things would seem fixed to you this is
how people are this is how society works
you know this is how everything has to
go and you kind of get used to it and
you don't try to solve these problems
but when you go from one culture to
another one environment to another you
realize that hey you know what's
completely the norm over here is
completely different somewhere else you
know what's polite here is offensive
somewhere else and then you see Wow
things are things can change it's not
set in stone so when you're in a new
environment you see problems you're like
wow it doesn't have to be this way you
can go on and try to solve it you can
create something better than the status
quo and I think that's really important
as entrepreneur and then also it trains
you to be more resourceful and you know
as an entrepreneur you're always it's
you're always solving a chicken-and-egg
problem you don't have money so how do
you hire people to build a product you
have priority customers a customer house
you raise money and you've never raise
money how do you do the rest of
everything so when you move from a
country to another you all obviously
have to adapt to a lot of things now I'm
a little lucky because moved to the
States relatively early in my in my life
so I had a little more time to adopt but
it was still it was still a lot of work
the I'm thankful that the first four
years in the US I was in Kansas and
Kansas there's not a lot of things going
up but it's an amazing place to learn
English because there's there's no one
else I can talk to you Chinese and you
know I have a lot of friends here in
California and if you're someone like
that Kylie take my suggestion so people
in California that I see you know that
they come to they come to California
from Asia and obviously everything's
kind of uncomfortable you don't speak
the language he feels in your country
might you might be very smart and clever
people respect you but when you talk to
you others in English you just sound
very stupid you know you just you're
just uncomfortable so just naturally you
hang out with people who also just be
Chinese and also have very broken
English so you're learning English from
each other it doesn't help you very much
so Kansas none of that it's everyone
everyone speaks speaks English you know
people thought I look like exactly like
Jackie Chan and gently at the exact same
time I don't know how but that's how it
is
and it was a great place to learn
English and my first year or I was it
when I was in high school I was taking
ESL English as a second language as well
and I joined the debate team at the same
time so I got slaughtered in every
tournament I was like I I was having my
little translator dictionary and I was
like dick dick dick dick in the other
teams I have no idea what they're
talking about and I'm like trying to
translate like I think he doesn't like
my thing he disagrees with this and it
was very sad but I learned very quickly
you know it's just like I know that I
won't die there's no and i will just
time will go pass and I'll learn from it
but I think that's the attitude that a
lot of entrepreneurs should have to
write when you run a start-up you kind
of problems all day long all the time
you know things are against you have to
go out with comfort zone you sound
stupid all the time but you have to keep
going you have to understand that you
won't die time will go by and you will
learn you have progress and by a lot of
hard work and luck you'll become
successful so hopefully my English right
now is this is kind of okay because of
that so and at the same time builds
tenacity for you because you're not
trying to not giving up you're going
through the comfort zone also at the
same time if you if you move around you
also you also learnt you to make more
friends because I actually moved like I
said I moved to Kansas as a tone as in
South Africa for a little bit i was in
vancouver southern california so when
you move around you also learn to make
more friends faster because you realize
that hey if you if you don't make
friends fast enough you leave and you
lose all your friends and you know
you're just always the foreigner so
again if you just grow up in the same
areas like a lot of people would just
have their buddies that they always hang
out with and the join a company they
just have their co-workers and the
network is relatively small and as an
entrepreneur obviously when you find
your co-founders we're employees you
need the best people to join your team
you can't have someone that's mediocre
because if one person music here that's
probably thirty percent of a company
that's mediocre and you're trying to
compete against a giant company with
thousands of employees who are who are
more than mediocre better than mediocre
so that definitely how that's definitely
really important for you to have a
strong network
and wheeshed and when you have a
start-up when you have an idea you know
you can go to someone you can bring the
best people on your team instead of just
that guy who lives next door was in your
classroom next month right ok so another
obviously there's some a lot of
obstacles for for coming from Asia and
that's all so different from just being
born agent in the States one definitely
is entrepreneur legal status you know
again there's no visa for it a lot of
people are actually facing the same
issues they're just going to keep in the
down low there's again language and
culture barriers so if you come you know
the way you do business and Asia is very
different from the way you do business
the u.s. so it's harder to get deals
through you know you don't know the
exact way to make people feel
comfortable working with you and so
there's a things any kind of business
person entrepreneur not needs to deal
with a lot of times when you create a
start-up your startup also lacks
diversity the same issue if you come
from a country it just when you create a
company it just tends to be that
everyone your company is around that
same country because you're just more
familiar with them you're just friends
with them and it's if you are a
american-born Asian you probably have a
lot more diverse friends and different
with different ethnicities and so in
create a company you probably have a
more diverse board in its obviously
there's a lot of usefulness and
strengthens having a diverse team and
there's a dear general stereotype that
you know people from Asia Asians are
generally stronger technically but
weaker managers so if you look at you
know when you go and do sales or you're
managing people people there's still
this thing about people feeling where
it's just you have to think a little bit
okay I have to if you'll have to work to
be open-minded to you feel like you are
a good manager a good entrepreneur you
can be a good CEO because a lot of
people are still expecting you to be
that technical role in the company and
so that's another challenge for being an
entrepreneur and another thing which is
twitch is true is that a lot of
education system in a lot of Asian
countries do not promote creativity I
know a lot of and I agree a lot of the
educating the u.s. don't do that either
it's still you know figure out what the
teacher wants you to say instead of
coming up to me creative but in Asia
it's worse you know it's all it's all
fill in the blanks memorize it and just
fill what you memorized you don't have
to understand it sometime
you don't have to know how to apply it
you just remember it and do it and so
that obviously goes against the entire
model being entrepreneurial and that's
another challenge and then another thing
is just difficulty to accept difficult
to access Capital especial in the US
again because you know over here you're
a foreigner you don't have as much
connections you don't sail as well
because of language barrier so there's a
lot of issues for for you to get access
to the capital that you need to start a
business and last slide so and Richard
didn't want me to talk a little bit
about if we have plans to expand to to
Asia so we do are planning to make a
plan to enter the Asian market obviously
has a start-up we don't want to be
spread too thin you know it's a small
team if we try to make it perfect for
for the globe you know we're going to be
sucky everywhere so we first want to
nail down the the US market where we
understand better at this point and but
we have been able making a lot of plans
to expand to to China which is a lot
obviously a lot bigger market and it's a
market where they've put a lot of value
and discounts in Ward points so in the
u.s. a lot of people still throw away
their punch cards I forget about it they
they don't care about this bug coupons
as much but in most Asian cultures
that's a huge thing you know people want
their discounts and there's actually a
funny story about Japan on this where I
probably won't have time to go over but
to to do that we also strategically or
even desperately I guess raise some
money through some individuals in Asia
and these are very influential people
there so they have a lot of connections
that can and they've been talking about
it or ready to bring our brand into
place like Hong Kong Shanghai and
Beijing so definitely we don't want to
move too fast but it's in the plans and
we have connections there so that's
something we want to do and I think
that's next slide is just to thank you
slide that and thank you for having me
and not be happy to answer any questions
you may have great thank you
actually I really want to thank both of
our panelists this has been great
information and there are so many
directions that I want the conversation
to go I think one of the things I want
to do is to kind of get back to your
company's for a minute with regard to
the competition that you face in some
ways you face different kinds of
competition because of the different
businesses that you're in ukiah I mean
there's a lot of stuff out there now
that our reward point applications and
you know is it shopkick where you walk
into the store and and you get points
just for walking in you have to buy
something on yours right okay so as a
startup company new in this space how do
you differentiate the company from all
the other stuff that's out there I think
for the key for this is really
understand your customers and their
needs and every customer is different so
their needs of different so shopkick is
something is great for a big our retail
store like a best buy because best buy
they have everything real estate they
just want to live walk in and shut walk
around and buy something but if you look
into something that's a smaller store
like a restaurant they don't want people
to do walking just to get points and
hang around and leave you know the job
of a restaurant owner is to or managers
get them to sit down eat pay money and
leave as soon as possible you know to
get that flowing yeah obviously they had
they opted you secretly then you have to
secretly figure out how to make them
enjoy the experience too but but that's
their goal like making sure people do
that and another thing is a lot of the
solutions out there are very heavy hard
to to implement there's a lot of POS
integrations another stuff and you
realize a lot of the the restaurant
owners at least they're not very
comfortable with complex technology some
of them don't even check their emails
very often and so the solution that we
gave is there's no POS integration
there's no you don't need internet you
don't even apply get in you just put it
there and it works and so this is
solution that's not as perhaps powerful
as some other tech companies out there
but it's something that our customer
base wants more so definitely figure out
what exactly what they want and then
folk
sing on that so are you comfortable
setting a little bit about how you've
done so far how many stores have signed
up in all or that kind of thing okay so
in the three months we've got a little
over a hundred stores to sign up most of
them the Bay Area some of them in
Southern California and Vancouver we
have some place in Chicago that ordered
and I think some new york shows and so
we are doing pretty well yeah okay good
we'll come back and talk about some
other things but surely I want to ask
you about wind vivo because it seems to
me that the kind of real issues you face
first of all is the expectation that a
lot of people have that an
over-the-counter medicine that sorry
wrong word over-the-counter therapeutic
is not going to be very effective that
it's essentially snake oil right and you
know how do you overcome that as a
startup company that doesn't really have
a brand to start with okay that's a
great question Richard that was a stand
up and talk about it that's exactly why
we start our company with the wound
healing product because that's the one
that will produce visually distinctive
result we know that Americans don't have
much patience they just want a result
yesterday okay so if you give them
something as T some ingredient or before
go home and brew your key no it's too
smelly it takes too long what am I going
to see the result so to build our
company's reputation I think we're going
to start with something that truly you
know it's truly effective and also
produce visually you know object
objective not result so when we show the
results to people coming to our booth in
a tree shows or presented to potential
partners on those practitioners and
doctors they extremely impressed by the
result this is not true snake oil
because you've seen it on the internet
there's a lot of noise there and people
show you this is a miracle product
where's the result and if it can maybe
show you some kind of a
magic before and after pictures
especially for male pattern baldness or
hair loss is magic or wrinkle wrinkle
production magic but when professionals
they look at the slow that step by step
tissue regeneration data from us they
know this is real and also a couple with
no research down by extremely
competitive and reputable research
companies and then kimchi in Silicon
Valley that gives a lot of credibility
okay and then follow our weekend with up
with some products like the oral
products like the psoriasis product that
might require a little bit of patience
but the pit they reported back saying
that they can feel the result pretty
soon because they live with the disease
for so long any change in the body stop
the itching or skin scales start to
disappear the feel it and they're
extremely encouraged okay I think my
next question for both of you that it's
really just burning that has to be asked
is okay so what were you surprised that
you needed to learn when you of a youkai
those are great a great list of things
about you know the value of inter
cultural knowledge and the value of
coming from somewhere else that's that's
really a great live were you surprised
when you started doing companies hear
about some anything what was the biggest
sort of thing you weren't prepared for
everything no it's just I mean I was
lucky that I decided to start a company
when I was in school so was not so a lot
of I didn't have the pressure that I'm
facing today I guess I had some time to
learn without the consequences of not
doing too well and so but a lot of it is
a lot of things just turn out to be a
lot difficult than you expected because
the plans always perfect your mind the
best time in a start-up here
is when the team first meets up say hey
that's awesome idea that's genius
everything's amazing right and then you
gotta things happen and just everything
takes four times longer than expected
and you had to switch things around and
so so it's just there's everything kind
of catches you unexpectedly but the
skill you need to learn is to be
prepared when things catch unexpectedly
but you can't really you can't really
train results what you're going to
expect yeah wrong yeah but you can't
anticipate everything that's happening
and that's the nature of it okay surely
you came to it from a different kind of
background I mean you were an IP
attorney for Wilson Sonsini so you did
that for a while you had worked in a
major you know biochem lab Oh what what
were the surprises when you actually got
out and became the CEO okay so unlike
your Chi I think I've seen their worst
situations being an attorney because
they will now come to you until there's
a big trouble so I would say I also will
help a lot of startups in the issues
facing startups I think pretty familiar
with but still after you get out of your
comfort zone get out of your extremely
lucrative no position and start your own
company and put your own money into the
company and try to raise money from NGOs
and institutional investors that's big
jump and to me what my heartfelt thanks
goes to my husband Jeff Chow here his
his a banker from Morgan Stanley and his
really supportive and he knows that this
is what I have been waiting for been
preparing myself all this biomedical
research and helping startups now it's
time to really to put all the expertise
together and work with great people and
come up with a great solutions to a lot
of people who suffer from the chronic
conditions okay yeah I'm nothing makes
me happier than to see like the guys
psoriasis disappear from his body and
people's eczema or the wound heal it's
just like it's extremely satisfied
satisfactory
money will come now hopefully that Mesa
okay good and both of our companies
actually have revenue already I mean
this is one of the distinctive things
about the panel this week is you know
you have a lot of startup companies
where they're in the middle of this sort
of dip in the red but um you've both
been able to really generate revenue
early and you know it looks very
promising from now let's open the floor
to questions Helen Helen was our speaker
last week Oh haven't I read your book we
have anti-aging products definitely
anticipate that kind of need cross the
room okay okay another question art
passions for Sharon is a tree hour later
on under 17 what was your process from
how and be constructing the ingredients
okay Oh quick as I it's gonna be a long
and sorry if I have to go through the
details but quickly what distinguish
when they've all from a lot of that i
would say feel good new age type of
products is that we follow although its
natural product but we do follow Western
type of us quality control and
standardization so for each ingredient
we wanted to know what are the main
components in the botanical that
actually contribute to the function
we're looking for and try to keep it
each batch you know with the same type
of no ingredients having this similar
percentage of that many ingredient so
it's called standardization in terms of
manufacturing we are we they are
manufactured here in the US so are you
actually sourcing from botanical
solutions that are in use or are you
really it was an idea that two people
tried something new it's a great
question
heaven half for for example the healing
balm we wouldn't want to reinvent the
wheel because this product has been used
on clinic for over 30 years and produce
a consistent result but this foreigner
in China and before we license that
however we did a very thorough due
diligence including did a little
experiment on ourselves don't ask what
okay and we know that works okay of
course later we design a series of a
well animal model sorry animal model
study to validate and compare the
product side by side with the standard
of care and its really impressed the
hell of a researchers anyway so then for
the lastly the colony control is
extremely important it's a lifeline of a
company so in order to build a
sustainable business we're here to stay
for the next hundred years or something
we better make sure that our product
standard to the test and so far as such
interesting to UK about reputation
management what surprised me is a report
I mean a testimonial dug out by my of
new chief marketing officer she was
doing due diligence on when vivo and she
miss sandy do better who's our world
when you meet a lady she was digging on
the web and trying to find bad press on
removal she couldn't find any instead
she finally review somebody wrote a
review give us a 10 a score of 10 4
score for Alberta nog so this low loss
because we didn't even know that's great
fighting but continue going on we wanted
to make sure that our products produce
consistently same result and with good
quality and certainly real quickly what
kind of a team do you have in the
company about how many people are
working full-time and right so far we
have in our team I would cook full-time
or close to four times four people but
they get extremely entrepreneurial very
highly motile here today Katie
d and Nancy dr. Nancy you and we also as
you know we build allies across the
Pacific with entrepreneurs are experts
in China and also manufacturing experts
in the US and academic researcher
collaboration collaborators here in
Stanford as well yeah okay oh you kind
of how big is your team my team we have
about maybe seven full timers and about
maybe five more part-timers and from
this point on how much of your time you
think will be devoted to new kind of
developments as opposed to expanding
this and and building out the service
side I think for since we are pushing
out a generation two of our product for
the next three months we are
anticipating a lot of RND work product
development and then I'm assuming as
when we launch will also do a lot of
refinement but F so maybe six months
down the road it'll be a lot more
expansion but at this point is more yep
I so your team is it very international
people from all over my team is mostly
from the US uh-huh but I guess
diversified in the US okay okay but are
there any other people from foreign
countries we have one person from Hong
Kong one person in Vancouver and I think
that is in most everyone else is was
mostly born and raised in the state okay
Charlie what about the before people oh
I would say we're all us we didn't have
to face the visa issue okay we got a
your citizenship a long time ago and
kate is born in Long Beach and sandy
born California and Nancy born in China
with our nutritionist nice expert so I
think where we join its kind of album
exhibition you don't care where they
come from so have a coma ingredients
nope ownership have gone yeah you have
to
it'd be willing to roll up the sleeve
and do the work because now I know it
got out of my comfort zone you really
have to do a lot of war sometimes
secretary job you go to the post office
mail the product that's what you have to
do but it's a very good experience
because you're not you're collecting
revenue okay good nice question back in
the back so where do you see
gamification going I've heard a lot for
corporate websites and getting into
mobile tech you see like the idea of
gamification kind of hitting some kind
of saturation point or do you think just
about any you know company enterprise
can use this kind of depends on I guess
I'll stand up for this one depends on
how broad you you define gamification
because making a process more
interesting more engaging is definitely
not a fad you know it's definitely
something that's here to stay like it's
it's just useful so but you clearly have
to have value clearly it clearly has to
be useful in itself if you think about
it a gamification for those who don't
know it's basically taking something
that usually do like eating out or go on
a website or check your email and and
adding some gaming mechanics to it so
adding some points leader board and all
that stuff to make it more interesting
and you're basically taking the things
that make games addicting and successful
and pull it into put into other stuff
but one thing that's really important to
note is that you know all games have
game mechanics in it all games have
gamification it but some games are fun
and popular while most games don't
succeed right so gamification itself is
not what makes something successful it's
really it has to be intriguing this has
been useful so if you if you take
something that's just not does not
create value and you add some layers of
gamification is not useful but if it's
something like that creates core value
that people that you know people want
anyway but you make it more engaging fun
I think that is here to stay and it
doesn't matter if they call gamification
or something else but the core of it is
something that I think has has a
long-term value for everyone good thanks
other questions so Charlie what are your
plans for kind of expanding beyond the
US market you're you're selling online
are you in stores as well or are you all
online right now of course when we
started easiest ways go online first
because there's no physical space needed
and now as our company grows and also
reputation grows we start to have
affiliates coming and clinicians and
nurses or you know even you know like
some some Clint I mean I would say
natural natural pathak practitioners as
far as some natural food store wanted to
formalize with us even online marketing
firms or we really form an alliance with
us so in right here in the US but
talking international expansion we have
to plan it well because you don't want
you know once you get into a market too
early on your brand if your brand is not
strong enough it can be easily arm
punished by people copying your left and
right and everything so we do plan to go
to Asia and Europe also because our
product I think oh very unique and it
will benefit a lot more people don't you
have to plan Wow and do the team for it
okay yeah it's coming soon go ahead
decide China it's being sorting channel
your products I know China not answer
now because we wanted to make sure that
it's it we have absolute good quality
control on and then we systematically
our market it throughout the whole world
so how do you control for quality okay
this is a very important because
financial product you know it's just
like cooking giving you give you the
same ingredients but because of the
process is different the result the
outcome is different so that's why the
whole manufacturing
process has to be controlled almost like
a coca-cola kind of very secret
treatment and then later you know you go
and try to find the distributors and no
no there's the formulation but there's
also making sure that each batch is the
same formula that's right yeah
fortunately and because i would say
you're not a relying on a single
ingredient in the in the mixture to
perform the magic it's a synergy there
so it would not if it's not like a very
powerful single ingredient if you differ
by 1% you're going to kill you know so
it's all nicely buffered in a nice
majestic and mixture as long as you have
that Jessica mixture even if there's a
difference in the one-percent 2% it
would not go too far so that's what I
feel comfortable about natural products
okay yeah naturally balanced youkai um
if you had started reward me in Taiwan
or someplace else in Asia would you have
done things differently do you think
surely I will but I think a big thing is
just the hardware has to support it
because and this is another thing about
creating company the pit you know
sometimes you create a company have had
some of my previous companies where
investors ask so how come no one did
this 10 years ago and it was because it
was possible and oftentimes you realize
one because there is some problem with
the idea or because the timing wasn't
ready or because some a lot of people
are doing it and therefore there's a lot
of competition that's really established
and so what this the nice thing about
reward me is that it only became
possible once there's enough
distribution of smartphones in the
States and you know that the equipment
has to be useful not with a GPS in it
with the the compass in it auto focus so
something like that wasn't possible even
like a year and a half two years ago and
so in taiwan i think it's just the mark
has to be ready and I and it just really
depends I
I just have a different whole different
solution that does not depend on
smartphones based on that so surely what
would make a market ready for when vivo
vs. not ready for windy though I think
if we launch our product 10 years ago I
would say it's too early because right
now you can see that people now taking
more proactive attitude toward they are
health and also thanks to the internet
that people can get easy access to
information they can do their own
comparison and do their own due
diligence if the company is not doing
well or sell snake oil yo for the
beginning maybe okay but soon you're
going to see complaint listen our
website bluffing right so I think if we
will stick to our principal and provide
the best quality products and produce
the you know reliable results I think
our company will grow and also with the
people's more attitude toward more
sustained sustainable growth and in
green the green revolution happening all
over the world I think away we have a
very good time in here okay go ahead
especially first game cake and then what
even the FK it will stop so how do you
find your first customer especially
paying customers are you I think for
both yeah getting the first paying
customer you can get people to try
something out but the first paying
customer you kind okay so so fat first
so first of all like a lot of stars
we're still trying to find the balance
point the optimized point about how much
money we should charge our customers and
even the revenue we did collect is more
like just testing the waters and it was
it's not a revenue model that we're
scaling up with or anything but I think
it just it really depends on your what's
your business doing because you know
what we do has inherent economic value
it's not something where it's a lot of
fun it's interesting it's something that
hey our stuff works we make more money
free increase your profits so therefore
it's a very as long as they're convinced
that they'll make more money because of
your product they're happy to pay
a you know a small amount of that and
also it's because in there in there in
the businesses mind they already know
that loyalty programs make more money so
sometimes it's hard to convey nothing's
like this but never done no loyalty
program in the world has existed then
convince them say hey you know if you
try to reward them a little bit it's
like what i have to give us something
like i don't believe in this then it's a
lot harder but you kind of go into what
they already have in mind and just have
a better solution to do what they've
already wanted to do I think that's
especially the pricing really sounds
like artistry you know this huh this
feels like it's right and then you test
it out and see what happens that kind of
approach yeah that's pretty
labor-intensive so yeah so like most
startups your first your early customers
you do have to talk to them a lot in
terms of value what what you need to
improve what features need to add what
kind of price point do they think this
is worth so at the beginning definitely
it's look you have to spend a lot more
attention on your early customers but
once you haven't nailed down that's
that's the point where you can scale
take that model and skill to a lot
bigger indeed at you guys right
depending on the value you provide and
we find that the beginning no you wanted
to give people the product to try so
they can experience it um but in extreme
cases well you know like professionals
they look at the data they say well this
really works better than anything I've
tried before yes I believe it well
they're convinced by the data okay
you're going to give them some samples
samples you really a work like magic and
people wants to try it and then they're
hooked and giving a very interesting
example just last weekend we are went to
some cisco do hope this now booth at the
trade shows like Green Festival and we
were selling the throw messengers for
people with the irritated throat at the
end of the show we already closed the
shop we have a 203 exhibitors rush in to
our to our booth and desperately want
our product because the thrall was on
fire because of a whole day talking and
we give them sample previously and they
remember it and it helped
and the desperate i needeth and they'll
be happy to pay whatever you're charging
them at at that point anyway so of
course you have a good market research
to set your price point yeah that's
question for these products of the
critics what are the risks and the
liability you're coming would be facing
because is no it's not over the counter
is actually more like hell product so
what's the reason they like busy you're
coming we face of course as a good
company you always have to carry product
liability insurance that's why we as a
lawyer that's what I would take care of
the first place um as I said we were
companies abuse build on the principle
of using food as medicine and we better
know what we're doing and the quality of
our ingredients and the way we
formulated would have to be the safest i
would say okay and of course we wanted
to educate the consumer about crack
usage of it so far and this really as
you can see search the web site there is
no complaint but we always wanted to be
vigilant about that and make sure our
product now has the highest quality and
also educate people about how to
correctly use it yeah okay maybe one
more question and i'll ask it so the
market in china is really you know
exploding for everything and i'll ask
both of you I'll start with you Kai um
do you really think that young
entrepreneurs from China should deal
with the problems of legal status and
all of this is it worth staying in the
United States a few years to develop a
company or should they go back to China
immediately and try to build something
there I would say if the current system
does not work or does not improve i
would highly recommend the chinese on
chinese people who are studying here
maybe two to go back to china
and create a company there so the system
meaning the immigration system that yes
they are they are Congress is working on
it but you know it's Congress is pushing
very slowly but I would say you know
running a start-up is risky enough with
you know and with all that layers on top
of it it's just a lot more risky you do
have to be kind of stubborn to want to
stay here and do it and do everything
here and almost not just in the sense of
entrepreneurship I've seen a lot of
people who you know finish school and
went into a corporate job in banking and
consulting and because of because
they're so dependent on the company
that's sponsoring them the company a lot
of the companies take it employers take
advantage of them they give them low pay
give them more work because they know
you cannot leave you know if you leave
you gotta you gotta go back to your
country so so some people would if they
go back to their country their their top
in the nation they're treated with a lot
of respect very sick still highly paid
but because they're a foreigner in the
US you know they're taking advantage of
and they Sten years of the life just go
by without getting to the point that
they can achieve so a nice modeling
because it sounds like we've got the
sweatshops no surely uh if you know what
what do you think should a long person
studying here who's from China is it
worth getting some experience in the
u.s. first or is it better to just go
back okay based on my own personal
experience I think I wouldn't want to
trade my experience in America young New
York and Silicon Valley with anything
else I think that's that's really just a
personal satisfaction life thing well I
think here in the US I i discovered i
discussed that entrepreneurship and
creativity i think this kind of culture
it's pretty unique in the whole world i
mean i wanted to you know get enough of
that and then go back and try to nurture
that kind of a culture in china and help
you in a bridge between Silicon Valley
and Chinese version of Silicon Valley
hopefully somewhere near Shanghai that's
in a linear term project or Michael we
may go back to Hungary
Oh what you visited magento yeah to help
entrepreneurs I'm Chopra narrows there
to be the good company and global
business okay home and I'd like to upend
my answer but yeah so I do agree that
you know if you if you go to school you
graduate here I think it's it as
valuable learning from how people do
business here so I would recommend you
know perhaps join and come join us
started helping out in college you know
go to experience you know different
startups you know listen to Richard
ashes lessons and all that stuff I
highly highly recommend learning can but
when it comes to starting your own
company and you know I i really think
that if you want to I always maximize
your chance of sex and you're not
stubborn about where you want to create
it i would say china has a big
opportunity and it's and it's your and
it has the rules that you know
everyone's has fair game we're over here
you don't have the right status you'll
have to you have to waste years of your
time just to get to the point where
everyone starts off with and that's
that's a challenge for entrepreneurs who
who want to succeed okay excellent
actually next week we're going to come
back to the whole idea about how do you
develop the skills you need as an
entrepreneur we're going to focus on
Southeast Asia have dr. ed rubbish
coming back next year next week to talk
about on the situation with teaching
entrepreneurship in Thailand and other
Southeast Asian countries first of all I
want to thank our panelists of people
who are really out in the world making a
success thank you and thanks so much for
coming
you